muy bien tenemos una pregunta con mucho
texto aquí la temperatura global anómala
indica qué tan caliente o fría es la
temperatura global promedio con respecto
a la normal durante un tiempo particular
un investigador condujo un estudio
observacional donde cartografía y
analizó los niveles de dióxido de
carbono en la atmósfera co2 y la
temperatura global anómala en grados
celsius desde el año 1960 esta es la
parte interesante el investigador
observó que la tasa de incremento del
dióxido de carbono atmosférico desde
1960 aproximadamente 4.0 por ciento por
década es comparable con la tasa de
incremento en la temperatura global
durante el mismo período de tiempo
aproximadamente 3.9 por ciento por
década con base en estos datos cual
conclusión es válida
muy bien existe una correlación entre el
incremento de los niveles de co2
atmosférico desde 1960 y el incremento
en la temperatura global anómala durante
el mismo período de tiempo esta parece
una opción válida
ambos datos se mueven juntos en la misma
dirección esto es lo que nos dice la
correlación no quiere decir que
necesariamente los niveles de co2 hacen
que incremente la temperatura o que el
incremento de temperatura hace que
incrementen los niveles de co2
simplemente dice que estas dos cosas se
mueven juntas que es a lo que se refiere
la correlación que tanto se mueven
juntas estas dos cosas me está gustando
esta opción pero vamos a leer todas las
opciones antes de elegir la que creemos
es la correcta el incremento en la
temperatura global anómala desde 1960
causó el incremento en los niveles de
co2 atmosférico durante el mismo periodo
de tiempo bueno nosotros no sabemos eso
no sabemos si existe causalidad aquí con
solo ver los datos del enunciado sólo
vemos datos de estas dos cosas que se
mueven juntas por lo que no podemos
decir que la temperatura ocasiona un
incremento en el co2 esto es un ejemplo
clásico en que dos cosas están
correlacionadas y se quiere implicar que
hay una causalidad es mucho más difícil
que hay causalidad de lo que es mostrar
que hay correlación definitivamente no
me gusta esta opción el incremento en
los niveles de co2 atmosférico desde
1960 ocasionó el incremento en la
temperatura global anómala durante el
mismo periodo de tiempo esto podría ser
una hipótesis razonable pero los datos
no indican esto quizá pueda existir otra
causa que ocasiona el incremento de
ambas cosas o quizá ambas cosas
aparentan moverse juntas pero esto no se
debe a alguna causa en particular no
podemos afirmar esto con solamente los
datos que están en el enunciado con el
hecho de que ambas se incrementan
aproximadamente el 4% por década desde
1960 no podemos afirmar que una causa a
la otra no existe una correlación entre
el incremento de los niveles de co2
atmosférico desde 1960 y el incremento
en la temperatura global anómala durante
el mismo período de tiempo seguro se
muestra una correlación podríamos decir
que no hay correlación si en alguna
década el co2 incrementará y al mismo
tiempo no
o disminuyera la temperatura global o en
otras décadas aumentará la temperatura
global y disminuyera el co2 o que en
otras décadas
ambos disminuyeron ahí sí podríamos
afirmar que no hay correlación de hecho
si una aumentará mientras la otra
disminuyera habría una correlación
negativa si se mueven juntas hay una muy
fuerte correlación positiva no hay
correlación cuando una cosa aumenta y la
otra disminuye o aumenta y cuando la
primera aumenta o disminuye la segunda
disminuye o aumenta espero que esto
último que dije tenga sentido aquí
definitivamente hay correlación porque
ambas se mueven juntas ambas se
incrementan y aproximadamente a la misma
tasa por década desde 1960 así que
también descartamos esta última opción
confirmamos que elegimos la primera
opción